let's get into what happened after 5a
leading up to all this first of all does
amanda deal find
love in 5b or season 6.
oh that's interesting um does he find
love um
yes he does find love but he finds it in
a very
different way in a way that i think is
going to shock the fans um
surprise them and then it's gonna be
unexpected um but i think it's gonna
make them
very very happy it's the it's the
perfect ending
uh for someone like amanda deal is it
someone with someone
who we've already met hmm how to answer
this question
it's oh my it's it's it's hard to say
but
he has a lot of love to give
he yeah so he has a lot of love to give
and he will receive a lot of love
[Music]
the giving the receiving yes yeah
yeah okay
after 5a came out the showrunners told
me that 5b is perhaps the most
emotional season yet would you
agree with that i would definitely agree
with that um
absolutely uh dennis hayes bird who who
plays good old dad
god who uh you know we're reunited uh
after 24 which is awesome
um he's gonna be a um
there all throughout 5b uh his presence
will be
felt um he has incredible scenes with
both both his sons dennis gets to act
with
every member of the cast whether they
know he's god or not
so i just think with the with the
introduction of god
you are going to be bringing in daddy
issues that
lucifer and amenities both have and some
of those need to be cleaned up
um and sometimes the way to clean those
up is you have to go through a little
bit of pain
and and emotion and revelations
uh so i definitely think that that's
gonna happen um
i'd also say there's gonna be something
shocking that happens um
towards the end of 5b that is going to
break
everyone's heart no it's
involving a mena deal involving lucifer
involved i can't
i i can't say who it involves but it i
what i what i do know is it's going to
break people's heart absolutely it's
going to break their heart that's not
the news i wanted to hear today i know
but you said it you know it's it's going
to be really emotional
uh okay um but i would just tell people
that
hey we have a season six
so even though your heart is gonna be
absolutely smashed
at the end of season five um
keep the faith it can be put back
together
yes 5a does leave off with
quite the showdown between all three
brothers i mean michael
and then you have him against amena deal
and lucifer and then god comes down
and he's wanting to fix i think all
three of them is that safe to say
yes absolutely okay we know it's a
direct
pickup right after that so what can you
tease about the first
scene in 5b um
that all of his sons are going to be on
their best behavior now that uh papa
has uh and all of his sons are going to
respect uh their father's arrival how
does
i mean throughout the entire season
god's presence
affect this trio
of brothers these brothers that have
issues with each other um
it's gonna have to get resolved with
with with their father um so i so i
so as so i do think that some stuff is
gonna go
down as the season goes on and there
will of course be one brother
that starts to disobey their father
proudly starts to
michael um i can't say but um
uh um that's probably a safe bet
um and uh and the other brothers are
gonna have to figure out
what to do with that is there a bigger
villain
than michael this season i think
it's safe to say michael remains the big
bad but
um he recruits
some un un expecting allies
um
uh he does he does recruit some people
and it's and it's pretty shocking
maze has a great story arc in uh in in
5b i mean everyone does but but
but but because you brought up maze maze
has a great story arc in 5b that i think
is going to make a lot of people
happy does she get a soul um
it's going to make a lot of people happy
we also learn in 5a that charlie
is immortal seemingly mortal
he catches a common cold he freezes when
time is stopped
how does that affect amena deal
throughout 5b
and is there a chance he's not actually
mortal well what i would say is um
it really throws a menadil off and uh
and a menadil has to deal with um
uh his he had certain expectations
uh for charlie and now it seems like
those expectations aren't going to be
met
and what does that do as a parent
when you believe certain things about
your child and it turns out not to be
true
and as a result of that i think that's
going to spin
a amena deal out and try
to and it will spin him in in directions
um where he's going to
take the challenge uh to grow
and to be accepting and to try to figure
out
well with this with this new information
um how can i help my son how can i help
humanity how can i help the world
um um as as amena deal uh likes to do so
i think he's gonna
put that on on on his back and that's
gonna affect
his journey from this point to the rest
till the series ends so there's no
chance that he's actually
celestial in some capacity or it's not
like when he turns 16
right well you know um never say never
never say never we do get a musical
episode in 5b
are is there a chance we get a musical
episode in season six
i think that we would have loved to have
done that in season six but because of
covid it's stuff like that that that
that we weren't able to do
um but what i what i can say
is you get a lot of um episodes that
will focus
on one of the characters so so you're
really going to get a chance to to see
every character in a different light
to uh follow them for uh and a
a special episode about about ella about
a mena deal about maze you know about
dan so
you're gonna get a chance to see it to
see a lot of that
i think the special episode this season
uh and i was blessed to direct is the
one
that um everyone is in they really
trusted me
and uh and so i would i'm i'm excited
for
for people to to take a look at that um
because i think they're going to really
dig it you and i um last time we talked
we talked about
the black lives matter movement do you
feel like there's been
a shift you feel like you guys cover um
i guess
like bigger social issues that need to
be addressed on television more
um on your show in these next two
seasons
um i think uh
do i think that we addressed it in 5b
um no but i don't think
um
listen i you know um um
it would be wrong of me to
call anyone out on this show
um when they're just doing what the
normal thing in hollywood is to do
right what i will say that they did was
um in season six we have an amazing
episode that we're calling our black
lives matter
episode and um this might be a little
bit of a spoiler but amanda dealer
decides to join
the police department and um
i don't think that you can in this day
and age
have a show about a police department
and not
tackle that issue um it would just be
criminal and so they do
they they tackle it full-on uh it's kind
of a call back
to our um episode in season four
that that we talked about they're
bringing back
that officer that racist officer who
has been promoted and so they partner me
up with
a more seasoned the detective
i'm going to mispronounce her name so
don't kill me marin but i think it's
marin
dunghy dungey um
and she's just brilliant uh all season
and
so she she she joins the cast this
season and
and her and i are our police partners
and amended those learning from her
i think it's going to be challenging and
difficult for people to watch but i
think we all need to watch it
and um doing an episode like that
is special and
and it's important how was it for you
to play a cop sorry if this is too
personal but after
everything that you've been through to
then play a cop what was that
like uh it i i won't lie it was it was
it was challenging
i think sometimes what's difficult for
people to understand is
the majority of police officers are good
people
and and and i don't think anybody that's
black or brown
is trying to say that they that they're
not good people
what we're trying to say is that the
system
in which they exist is a
system right and that system needs to
change
from within so we need to dismantle
these systems
and rebuild them so that good people
thrive within good systems and
the bad people get expelled i think
someone
like amanda deal that's that's his his
focus
and so i think we need to continue doing
doing stories like this
and um showing people um what
what my and others experience is
in this country we have a long way to go
we have a lot of hard work to do
uh we're going to be in this for a while
but we're moving in the right direction
i'm so glad that you guys are doing that
storyline i think that's amazing
what what is a mena deal like as a cop
um a little self-righteous you know uh
as a menadil is right um i think
amenities sees things and he sees like
what that's
that's wrong so that must that must be
fixed and
you know uh i think amanda deal has to
learn how to be uh
political how to be thoughtful uh
um how to work um
how to work within a system to uh knock
down a system
and i think he has to learn that he just
can't always be so
reactionary you know that you need to
have
thoughts and plans and allies
changing gears a little bit as we wrap
up will
lucifer finally tell chloe that he loves
her in 5b he was so close at the end of
5a
in season six um
i'm pretty sure that's going to exist
[Music]
somewhere
you